plusieurs coups de coeur cette semaine
au ciné cette le premier c'est un
thriller polar espagnol qui s'appelle la
colère d'un homme patient qui est très
peu distribuée qui est très peu visible
dans les salles
je vous conseille vraiment c'est
l'histoire d'un homme qui revient huit
ans après un meurtre pour se venger en
fait de ce meurtre que tout le monde a
oublié c'est très efficace très sont
très noirs comme souvent les films
espagnols les polars espagnol je repense
à la isla minima c'est dans la même
veine et puis deux autres coups de coeur
qui sont des films que j'ai découvert
que j'ai eu la chance de découvrir à
cannes qui sont pas encore sortis en
salles mais que je vous engage d'ores et
déjà à surveiller et surtout à les voir
massivement quand ils sortiront le
premier c'est carré 35 un magnifique
film d'eric caravaca l'acteur qui est
plus connu en tant qu'acteur c'est un
film sur la mémoire sur les secrets de
famille qu'il faut absolument voir qui
est très beau et le deuxième c'est le
film dont tout on parle c'est 120
battements par minute
un très beau film sur acteurs sur le
sida sur la lutte d'act up réalisé par
robin campillo
c'est ce que je peux être candidat je
suis possédé
[Musique]